Justin Bieber and Selena Gomez reunite
at her house can we we keep each other
company
[Music]
Jelena appeared to be friendly exes the
former couple who dated on and off from
2011-2014 were spotted hanging out at
Selena's Studio City residence with a
group of friends from church until close
to midnight on Sunday a source tells et
it was not romantic and there are no
signs of Justin and Selena getting back
together quote it's totally platonic
Selena is still with the weekend and she
only sees Justin as a friend you know my
personal life and my family and friends
I'm just a really happy place the source
adds the hands to myself Seager helped
Bieber get involved in the church in an
attempt to help turn his life around
it's an emotional time in my life for
sure
well the Biebs isn't the only former
friend Selena is making amends with 25
year old Selena recently reunited with
her pal Demi Lovato according to our
source the pop star has a new outlook on
life quote given everything she's been
through with her health it's not
surprising that she's making an effort
to reconnect with people she knows how
precious life is getting to do things
that I'm passionate about with the
people that I love
[Music]